we wait for the white smoke to come from
the chimney of the jacksonville jaguars
facility announcing that they're finally
signing tim tebow
greg mcelroy who was a jets backup
quarterback
when tim tebow was a backup quarterback
and a very part-time
tight end here's mcilroy from late last
week
appearing on siriusxm espnu with his
thoughts
on this possibility of tim tebow joining
the jaguars is a tight end
like everyone says oh well now he's
finally doing what he should have done
10 years ago
by switching to tight end y'all we were
with him in the jets
we were like i played with they tried to
switch them too tight end and he wasn't
good
like that's what people don't
acknowledge they're like oh
they'll just use them as a taste some
hill player tim ran a 4-8
tayson hill runs a 4-4 i mean they're
just two totally different players
i mean tim is a good dude and i hope the
best for him
but it's a laughing it's a sideshow
and it's and that's what it will be come
training camp time
and i think it kind of undercuts and
undermines a little bit of what urban
meyer is trying to build
as someone that's gone through training
camp with tim they're gonna be players
in there that are rolling their eyes
with the amount of attention the fourth
string or fifth string tight end gets
and it's going to piss people off and as
a result
it's going to affect locker room
chemistry just like it did with us at
the jets
not because anyone had any animosity
towards tim has had
animosity towards the coverage the tim
receives so
that's i think gonna be i think it's a
stupid move
you're starting your tenure at in
jacksonville
you're setting the tone but people say
well he can help with leadership
let me get let me tell you what helps
with leadership in the nfl
money like you want guys to be
incentivized
pay him that's what it comes down to
there's no leaders
oh well he's a old consummate leader no
guys follow the money
if you guys are getting paid big smack
and they're performing at a really high
level that's who they'll follow
you know greg mcelroy really needs to
come out of his shell and no i mean damn
he laid it out there by the way on
behalf
of greg mcelroy sorry manchester or one
of the things mcilroy said during that
clip but
you know chris um hey and
it occurred to me yesterday to just ask
the question what's up with tebow
because urban meyer the coach of the
jaguars said over the weekend he'd get
together with his staff on sunday
and they'd make a decision well what's
the decision yeah what
i i really do feel like they have to
figure out what they're going to do with
gardner minshew so when tebow
lands they can maximize the tebow 15
because you can't start selling tebow 15
if you still got
minshu 15 on the roster that's such a
superficial obvious point
but it won't have the same problems it
won't have the same effect i agree with
you there i mean
listen he's associated with the number
15. i'm with you
you know and hey listen greg mcelroy i
think he made a lot of the points that
we
we made last week except we tried to be
a little bit more delicate with it and
he just came out and
said which i i appreciate and i respect
but he's right i mean you know the way
he said it it it hits home
it hits hard the way he said it too yeah
i mean we we talked about this
hey it's the circus when tim tebow comes
to town
it is empires will resent a guy who's
like
wait he didn't take a rep in practice
but every media member is going to be
around him in the locker room and talk
about him and give him
you know coverage and hype and
everything like that that will make
players
annoyed right i mean that that's just
part of the situation
and yeah it is a first-time nfl head
coach trying to build a culture
and this is where you know i don't know
i feel like the fact that it's delayed a
little bit here recently
i think urban meyer maybe is like taking
a step back and realize wait
i love this guy i love him i mean we
know that he'll do anything for him
i mean you never i mean he's obsessed
with tim tebow
so there's a real place in his heart for
him but
is it really the best thing for his team
and that
going forward and everything that way
and i feel like the delay
i don't know lately i've gotta got the
feel that i think he's gonna
he's gonna say no to this because he's
he's noticed kind of the
the attention around this and maybe what
it could do to a football team
and it's so much more than just giving a
guy a spot
on the 90-man off-season roster that
surely
isn't the end game the end game is
finding a way
to get him on the football field and i
think at the
very least what happens is he's on the
practice squad
and he's one of the guys who gets called
up for the game day roster because you
can now bring up two guys from the
practice squad no questions asked
every week that's that's the rule
non-pandemic that's the rule
so you can have tebow part of the team
comes up put him in a uniform wait for
the right opportunity to throw him a
football and
because if you sign him and you sell a
bunch of his jerseys
and then you cut him in august
you're going to have some people who are
not happy with the fact that they bought
all these tebow jerseys
so i and and that that's one of the
things that that i can't process yeah i
hear
people like oh what's the big deal
you're just giving them a 90-man roster
spot well the big deal is
you're gonna you're gonna use this guy
to generate interest
and sell tickets and sell jerseys and
then you're gonna cut him
no if you're signing him you gotta be
ready
to make him part of your team for 2021
that's the thing that people
are missing and the other side of it too
because i've seen this argument ah
what's it matter
it's a 90-man roster it's just one of 90
spots there's 90 spots right now
yeah but
there's another guy out there who
deserves that spot whoever it is
whatever position he plays
there's a guy out there who's been
busting his ass and dedicated to
football and
can't get an opportunity and they're
going to take one of those 90 spots oh
it's 90 spots
it's yeah and there's hundreds of guys
who want them
you're giving that 90th spot to the
dog-faced boy the bearded lady
whatever sideshow act you want to call
it that's what you're doing
what's it going to do to your football
team what's it going to do to your
locker room
what's it going to do beyond those
people who
flock to the team shop and buy
tebow 15 and then start agitating for
tebow to play
not just tight end but quarterback
that's it there's a deeper issue here
yeah
buyers just glossed up he's just glossed
over right emperor of gainesville
emperor of columbus not emperor of
jacksonville that's not how it works at
the nfl and maybe you're right
maybe he's realizing from the resistance
he's getting
that that this may not be the best thing
for me to do i i think it's scary
you know and i'm i'm rooting for urban
meyer you know i've known him
since i was in high school it recruited
me i mean i got a lot of respect for
everything he's done
you know just from a guy that's never
get you to play tight end well no he
didn't but he but
but he's you know just from a guy that's
on the outside looking in
i respect everything about him and if i
was to advise him i'd go man this is
just ain't smart i
i'm with you you made the the other good
points where i wanted to go
you're right i mean then there's going
to be the clamoring
oh wait it's pre-season give tebow the
ball we're at the one-inch line
let him run it in come on
you know i mean that that's where he was
built you never saw a fan base go so
crazy over
a guy getting a an inch and a half gain
for a touchdown on the
on the one inch yard line hey we got
percy harvin hey we got all these
all-stars
let's let tebow run it in from an inch
and a half touchdown
like yeah that's where you're gonna get
issues
and it's just gonna build and build and
that's where yes i think it is scary and
you're right i think the cl
if he gets on the team or he's there the
clamoring for him to do
something at quarterback is gonna become
a thing too
and i just think it's for a young
football team they got a lot of young
players
with the an inexperienced coaching staff
to a degree
with college guys and everything like
that i just think it is it's a scary
scary sideshow that i think could derail
things in a big way
this is something i never do and i can't
say never because i'm going to do it now
i'll say this is something i
rarely do what i rarely do is read
on this show word for word something
i've written
at pft but i like how i put it last
night and i won't be able
to duplicate it so let me just read this
passage
through it all there continue to be two
camps when it comes to tim tebow
one camp shrugs at giving tebow a job
that justifiably could go to someone
else
one camp touts tebow's leadership work
ethic and drive
one camp thinks the other camp is
blinded by the fact that it simply
doesn't like tebow
the other camp contends that a football
roster represents a zero-sum game
and that by giving tebow one of the 90
positions someone else more deserving of
that opportunity won't get it
the other camp wonders why if tebow's
attributes are so desirable to an nfl
roster
the jaguars have become the only team
remotely interested in offering him a
roster spot in years
the other camp thinks the first camp is
blinded by the fact
that it simply likes tebow too much
right
it's a microcosm of our broader
yeah right isn't it i i mean yeah
another word starting with t that has
four letters behind it
isn't that the litmus test right now
listen is that what we're
fundamentally dealing with here i don't
want to go there i know i've said my
white privileged things and i don't i
know but you're right
i mean i know that not right there and
you know what like even my dad he said
something to me yesterday he's like
that's not right you're not saying the
right phrase there that's just not right
and i was like you know
i understand but like i guess what i'm
trying to get at is a little bit what
you're trying to get at to a degree
i mean yeah i mean listen i don't know
what i put it it's he's the most
overrated sports figure in our
our country this century i this there's
no other way for me to say it
i mean he won the heisman going nine and
four nobody wins the heisman going nine
and four
he won the sec he didn't even win sec
player of the year
darren mcfadden did but because he was
such a media creation
and urban meyer would just never would
stop talking about him
he got all the credit on a team with 22
nfl players that were like
all pro players like good one of the
greatest college teams ever
it was just tebow tibo tebow never
anything else you didn't hear anything
else
so he's a creation and that's where it's
like that's to me where the like
and again i know it's not the right
phrase but there's just this cult
this privilege aspect of just like yeah
this figure of a guy
for what he stands for to a degree
instead of the merits being looked at
really
and i think that's what bothers me it
bothers most athletes
and the people that have been in the
locker room and everything like that to
where it just
it doesn't make sense but that's when
you hear the response the merits of the
work ethic the leadership and the drive
but but
why has the rest of the league ignored
him yes
for 10 years mcilroy said it best yes he
did
problem you're getting into is the fact
that you're gonna have
media descend on jacksonville to cover
the fourth or fifth string tight end and
other guys are gonna resent it and i
don't care that there's been a dramatic
overhaul of the jaguars roster
these are still grown professional
individuals in that locker room who are
going to see what's going on they're
going to roll their eyes and
say what in the f did i sign up for and
trevor lawrence is the number one pick
and
hey he works hard and does everything
too but nobody will talk about it if
that comes to that in training camp it's
only gonna be about one guy and then
now you're squashing the leadership of
the guy you're trying to make the leader
of your football team
and some other young guys who you want
to have a voice of your team because
it's
all the media talks about is hey did
did tim motivate you to drink gatorade
better today
did he because he drank it like this
and then i saw you stop do that too
and it like did it motivate like that's
where it just snowballs into this crazy
crap where you're just like
it's insane they're gonna give them
credit for everything so
that's where it just it's insane i don't
even know any
i've seen the argument chris that that
this is some sort of
next level genius yeah right admire to
allow trevor lawrence to develop without
a lot of extra attention oh my gosh
oh my gosh i mean he hasn't got
attention to clemson either he can't
handle it he's been a little tough there
yeah what the hell is that i know the
unquestioned number one pick we've known
he was going to be the number one
overall pick in the drive from the
moment he was a true freshman at clemson
and this guy needs cover yeah this guy
needs someone out there who's going to
be
all the attention right right it's
insane i don't it's some of the thoughts
that come out of that side like you're
talking about
are insane and it's like you you don't
you don't know how to where to start
with the argument sometimes
i will say this the last 15 minutes
would have been a lot more entertaining
if we did set up phony arguments and one
of us took
the other side i mean it was fun the way
it was but can you imagine
if we naturally disagreed on this my god
you're right we'd have some fireworks we
really we might actually not like each
other at the end of the segment
after today by the way by the way do you
know the only person who won the heisman
trophy from a team with a losing record
do you know do you know ooh
you know um i'm gonna say it's somebody
on notre dame
back in the day paul horner yes paul
hornett yes
boom boom play the horns well done thank
you very
much i think that counts
i love that sound i love it more when
it's directed to me answering a question
right
that counts as winning the uh the first
pick in the draft that we're going to do
later
all right good i'll take it hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports